I am welcoming back today year on Brook
who is chairman of the ein Rand
Institute and host of the year on Brook
show this is number four in a series of
discussions produced in partnership with
the eine Rand Institute we've talked
about eine rand and objectivism we have
discussed capitalism we talked we tried
to talk about welfare but we ended up
talking about a lot of other things as
well that I think we're very interesting
let's maybe now tart start to tie in
some of the principles you've been
talking about and I've been talking
about into politics and 2019 maybe
starting with what's most immediate
around us what would be the iron Rand
Objectivist interpretation or critique
of something like the Trump doctrine
philosophy to the extent it exists and
administration well I would say the main
critique of Donald Trump would be that
he doesn't have one that is he doesn't
have a doctrine of philosophy Donald
Trump is a narcissist and a pragmatist
he is completely focused on you know
what he thinks will work tomorrow for
him in some emotional sense I'm not even
sure how he perceives for him there is
no strategy there is no policy there is
no agenda long-term and it suddenly
isn't an agenda that's consistent with
objectivism there's no real sense in
which this administration is full free
markets yes there are a few areas where
there's some deregulation going on but
compare that to raising tariffs or to
trying to do what what is caught often
called managed trade or even Industrial
Policy where Donald Trump will call up
the CEO of a company and say no no you
can't close that plant or you can't move
that plant to Mexico which is a complete
negation of my view of free markets
where the president doesn't get involved
in business decisions and I don't even
consider that policy like I said when
that happened that is not even if you
like what he did that's not really a
policy that could be extrapolated to the
entire country that's just him calling
someone and basically saying take some
money to change your mind
it's him wanting to be the CEO of the
country and I don't I don't believe the
country needs a CEO we need a president
who is dedicated to protecting us and to
fleeing us up because I think we're I
think we're very unfree as we discussed
in previous episodes and I'd like to see
a prayer
loosening their strange fingers up now
so I liked I liked the corporate tax cut
I think that's the the one thing that he
did which was good I liked some of the
deregulation although I think it's too
little and too insignificant but the
corporate tax rate was good but if at
the same time
you spend like a drunken sailor and
there's no tomorrow and you've got to
running trillion-dollar deficits I mean
it doesn't matter how much you cut taxes
I believe a you know government
shrinking stimulus is a stimulant to the
economy it actually increases economic
activity it's not cutting taxes it's
less government spending which
stimulates the economy so again this is
counter to many of the neo-keynesian out
there and many of the the polls oh but I
believe that the way to get the economy
to grow at four or five percent is to
get the government to shrink
dramatically first shrink spending then
shrink taxes but corporate tax cuts okay
they were insanely high and indeed I I
wish they would be simplified I don't
like the fact that he left all the
exclusions and deductions and loopholes
and all that stuff i you know i want i
want taxes on a postcard no vote for
individuals and for corporations flat
and simple and it's close to zero as as
humanly possible um so we just thought
let's explore that a little bit cuz
there's a lot there so of course I
reject the idea that you can cut your
way to prosperity but let's not focus on
that because we're trying to interpret
the the Trump doctrine to the extent
that it exists you talked about keeping
us safe I think that this is an
interesting question mark because over
the last twenty years or maybe even
longer in the United States political
dichotomy the right has talked a lot
about how the left are they feminized
the left they won't keep us safe they
won't use the military they'll let us be
taken advantage of I'm curious where
your framework would interpret that
because what I see is that okay maybe
the left will grow the the military
slightly slower than the right will but
that basically everybody who's had a
serious shot at being president over the
last many decades is going to listen to
what the generals say and are going to
have a very similar policy on national
defense the difference may be how many
proactive wars of choice do they get in
often I think that's probably right for
most people on the left I'm not sure you
know I haven't really dug into Bernie
Sanders foreign policy and I'd be
suspicious of it but but it's hard for
me to say but suddenly there was very
little difference in foreign policy
between Obama and Bush although there
was an difference in emphasis Bush
believed in America should lead Obama
believed that you needed a firm
consensus and America should follow you
so then in Libya I disagree with all of
them I mean again like in every area I
you know I I believe the entire spectrum
is wrong I think none of none of the
parties actually engaged in what is
truly an American self-interest and I
have been very critical of American
generals and American military in terms
of the way they fight was was and in
terms of their doctrines and and I do
not believe America needs to have troops
in 120 different countries I don't
believe that that makes us safe I don't
believe that but I do believe in in
fighting wars when you have two the
difference is I believe in fighting wars
where you crush the enemy you really
devastate them and then you come home I
don't believe it was that build
democracies I don't believe in sticking
around I don't believe in rebuilding
after the war so you know again an
Objectivist foreign policy is a very
different fall policy than the consensus
left and right but it does sound Euron
like under that standard I mean are
there any military engagements from the
last 40 years that would be okay under
that umbrella where because again if the
focus is on no coercion and non
aggression and all of these things I'm
having a hard time thinking of recent
military engagements that were truly
necessary under that rubric so I would
have been an Iran was against Korea was
against Vietnam very much against
Vietnam and I would be against pretty
much all the other wars with the
exception of they had to be a response
post 9/11 and indeed I believe and we at
the end of an institute a decade for
response well before 9/11 because we
thought that the the the violence coming
out of Islamism or jihadism however you
want to call it it started well before
9/11 and had to be dealt with and it was
the appeasement of Jimmy Carter Ronald
Reagan and every other president
afterwards that basically made nine
eleven possible but they had to be
response I think the response that
existed was the wrong response well it
was the wrong country right wrong
country okay means it was the wrong
country rock was he relevant the only
two countries in my view that are
relevant for for an ongoing war which I
think exists today I think did you hadas
is still alive and well Isis you know
maybe he's been crushed for now but will
resurrect in a different form somewhere
else the only two countries that matter
in this fight a two one
you know we've got sanctions against
Iran but you know I don't think the
sanctions are doing much in the second
is our best friend which is Saudi Arabia
I think those are the two countries that
matter those are the two countries we
should have in a sense declared war on
after 9/11 and we should have dealt with
pretty thoroughly at the time I think
because we didn't these issues fest and
Wolf Festa and will fester for a very
long time because we haven't dealt with
the people who fund and ideologically
support and encourage these ideas and
these actions on behalf of all these
other groups that actually do the
violence is there a country right now
that you would say is the closest to in
its form of government and in its
application of government closer than
the United States
- Randy an Objectivist philosophy I mean
it's it's a hard question I mean the
bottom line is no because because I
think every country in the world right
now is so far away from my conception of
government there's suddenly countries
today in the world that are moderately
moderately freer than the United States
not much but moderately so you know
whether it's and here I hear the problem
is you've got social freedoms and
economic freedoms and they sometimes
clash
yes Singapore might be a little
economically free up but it's less free
on social issues I don't like it right
Hong Kong we know what's happening in
Hong Kong's I certainly don't want to
raise dong Kong but certainly Hong Kong
before the Chinese took it over I think
what it was closer than the United
States but again not consistent maybe
New Zealand today in in certain aspects
but so inconsistently and and so often
for the wrong reasons
that no you know there's no kind
she in the world today and look it has
to be the United States in this sense
and and I think the Constitution is
flawed I know I know that's horrible to
say and people so no that's great to say
and certainly people on the right will
come after me for saying you should is
flawed my my favorite document really my
favorite political document in all of
human history is the Declaration of
Independence because it lays out the
foundation and the structure and the
purpose of government and the purpose of
government is to protect individual
rights and that's it and it's that they
say that is the purpose for which
governments are instituted and only
America has that moral foundation only
America has that foundation that in the
even at the beginning it didn't fully
obviously execute on because of slavery
and other things with primarily slavery
which is a big deal
it didn't execute on but it has it has
that seed of we understand that there's
such a thing as rights and government is
there to protect them no other country
has that you know Japan has it because
McArthur put it in the Constitution even
though they didn't want it but I don't
know that they understand it American
culture has that so I think I've always
thought that it's America that's going
to move in that direction if any country
ever does now I've I've reconsidered
that position because America's got so
far away from my conception of what a
good country should be and and in the
presidency of Donald Trump is may be far
more pessimistic about America than I
ever thought I would be that that maybe
it'll happen somewhere else but there's
no indication that that somewhere else
is imminent so there's any country
moving in that direction today so let's
explore why that is I mean one of the
arguments that anti socialists will
often make is listen everywhere it's
been even sort of tried has been a
disaster and there's a reason why you
don't see any great socialist successes
today okay let's apply a sort of similar
idea to Randy and objectivism and the
the conception of government that you
have what are the forces that have
prevented it from taking hold and is it
possible that every time some element of
government starts going in that
direction it doesn't go super well and
that's why we've not seen it know its
exact opposite ah every time every
and this is the difference between a
socialist argument about it's never be
tried perfectly and how argument is
different socialism to the extent that
it's practiced always fails and we can
talk about examples where you think it
hasn't and I'm fine with that right
capitalism to the extent it's practiced
has always succeeded always and and we
could go through example after example
it always succeeds only by the standards
you apply for success which is would
take a big issue with so let's start
let's just apply success as something
simple economic growth wealth creation
now that's not the only standard it's
not the only stand for me right but
let's just take one one standard a being
it everywhere it's tried it produces
economic growth way above anything any
other system and it creates wealth and I
I will even answer that the poor were
better off everywhere it's tried every
place it's tried every continents tried
every time it's strike now the problem
with capitalism is not that it doesn't
succeed the problem with capitalism is
it not that it doesn't create wealth it
does Hong Kong being a fantastic example
the United States in the nineteenth
century the whole industrial pollution
being a fantastic example the problem
with capitalism is that we don't have a
mall foundation for it it goes back to
our discussion you know for a few shows
back the fact is that people don't
believe that it's okay to be
self-interested in capitalism is the
system of self-interest look capitalism
is absolutely unequivocally about
individuals pursuing their self-interest
as consumers we all want to buy the
stuff that makes our life better and as
producers well I want to produce stuff
that'll make us rich although we love
producing we enjoy producing it's not
about social well-being it's not about
the common good it's not about any of
those things it's about people pursuing
self-interest unless you have a mall
foundation for self-interest which other
than Iran and Aristotle nobody has ever
presented one it falls flat so even the
founding fathers even knowing that funny
in the Declaration they say you have an
inalienable right to pursue happiness
this still though believed morally if
you look at the Jeffersonian Bible if
you look at what they write about
morality they still are bought into
Christian morality they still believe
that the purpose of life is
self-sacrifice and the purpose of life
is still at some extent the idea of
sacrifice and social
being so even Adam Smith the wealth of
nations rights you know the bigot
doesn't make the bread for you he makes
the bread for himself so self-interest
is what drives the capitalist economy
but then he says but self-interest is
not a good thing
we don't like self-interest it's kind of
yucky right it's not a sign of virtue it
turns out though he says that if you add
up all these vices it turned it is an
invisible hand that turns it into a
virtue nobody buys that nobody buys that
if everybody commits vices there's a
virtue at the end of the rainbow what I
try to convince people silly what Iran
try to convince people is no the very
pursuit of self-interest done rationally
done long-term is virtue and that's
essentially what capitalism is about so
I think capitalism is rejected because
of guilt because of morality because but
what about those needy over there how do
we help them and we don't take the
long-term perspective we don't let them
rise up by themselves through the market
system I think that's the problem not
any failure within capitalism to
actually produce the goods well so it is
a very that is a parallel explanation to
what the and I'm not a socialist what
the socialist would argue you just
disagree that they're actually telling
it as it is they would disagree that
you're telling it as it is right I mean
it is a very similar line of reason
though by any standard by any standard
they can pick the standard they want
they have failed every single time
they've tried it and the more
consistently commie
consistently socialist it's being the
greater the failure in capitalism the
exact opposite is occurred you you know
you can pick I can pick 20 different
standards a life expectancy every any
standard of human wellbeing the more you
try capitalism the more to be successful
and we can objectively go look we can
live with like expectancy in in Hong
Kong before capitalism after capitalism
we can live with life expectancy in the
Soviet Union before communism after
communism okay but the problem with that
is the problem with that is there were
even if we grant as we have to because
it's the truth even if we grant that you
saw the life expectancy increases
coincide with the introduction
of this pseudo capitalist system it is
now reversing that there was an initial
there was low-hanging fruit to be gained
Angus Deaton I know I've mentioned in
before writes about this as well we're
now seeing life expectancy for many
groups in the u.s. actually start to go
back down one group and only one group
and the causes are pretty well known and
it causes that are completely caused by
the by the mixed economy by the statist
element that is the two things that are
killing middle-aged white men and that
that is that is where the life
expectancy is going down and and I've
read deepens paper on this right and the
causes are the the the opioid epidemic
and you could argue about what caused
the opioid epidemic but I would argue to
a large extent it's the FDA and
socialized health care they're part of
socialized health care we haven't knows
that I disagree with but ok Medicaid and
the guidelines the doctors have as a
consequence and second it's it's suicide
rates and I think there's there's no
question that in the United States
there's a massive number of people who
feel feel disenfranchised that feel
alienated from the culture and from the
economic reality of the country they've
been promised certain things that have
not come reality and we can talk about
why that is and and and there's a lot to
talk about that I think it's an
interesting topic but it's it's why
Donald Trump got elected it's why I
think Bernie Sanders does so well it's
there really people who feel
disenfranchised and they want to smash
things they want somebody new and many
of those people unfortunately the same
people taking opioids and the same
people committing suicide and that's the
driver and then add to that a very
unhealthy lifestyle that America is
engaged in but if you abstract from that
yeah but you're on I think that it's
it's a little bit unfair to mention
opioid and suicide and then throw in and
some people live an unhealthy lifestyle
when actually that is one of the primary
causes of a ton of the preventable
conditions and it is arguably directly
related to lack of regulation the
so-called capitalist system that you say
needs to be put in full force we can't
minimize that exact opposite it's
completely the consequence of statism
it's a consequence of government-run
schools it is the consequence of a food
pyramid that has given people bad advice
for we've talked about that now
talked about that it is a consequence of
coddling people it's a consequence of
letting people believe that if they were
born in Ohio they can always live in
Ohio and there will always be a job in
Ohio and manufacturing is coming back to
America as if it ever left it didn't it
just was replaced by machinery and
computers and robots and and it's it's
giving them false hope and instead of
getting in a car and driving to where
the jobs are and the plenty of jobs in
America today they sit there waiting
because they were promised so I think
yes we've got a massive cultural problem
I think that cultural problem is
primarily caused by too much government
regulation too many government promises
too much government involvement na naaa
a loss of what I consider the American
spirit which is bootstrapping yourself
even when you poor figuring out a
solution going to where the jobs are you
know it's hard I'm not saying it's not
hard it's very hard it but but that
mentality that attitude of kind of
really orient getting that I think is
being destroyed in America by you know
really since then you deal by offering
people this goes back to welfare state
by offering people goodies to stay home
and not and not be ambitious as
ambitious as they otherwise could yeah I
mean as I pointed out the goodies are
very very anyone who would be satisfied
to say these goodies are going to be my
livelihood is on a very far end of the
spectrum but because you're mentioning
the goodies this maybe is a good
opportunity to raise Scandinavia so you
have asserted during our talk here that
the the closer a a country goes to
actual free-market capitalism as you
would decide it the more freedom people
have the more prosperity there is I
think we would probably agree although
you'll have plenty of an opportunity to
disagree that in Denmark Norway Sweden
and Finland in general there is a
tighter business regulatory environment
as we would see it and yet and and I'm
preparing for the counter talking point
on that and yet the and there is a
stronger social safety net and there are
taxes that are robust and and can cover
the programs they've determined they
want to
and yet those countries still score very
well in terms of the business
environment those countries score very
well in terms of happiness they score
very well in terms of standard of living
so they seem to have reigned in the
degree to which they are total
free-market capitalist but yet they are
doing very well so I would I would
encourage you to look into the data sure
because I don't think I don't think
that's true of Scandinavia most of what
you said is true I'm not gonna you're
not gonna question it but one estimate
most of its pretty good most of its
pretty good yes we'll get to that okay
and one one respect I think is false and
it's an important respect because I
think it makes all the difference on
government regulation of business
Scandinavia regulates far less than the
United States depends on the country
suddenly Denmark and certainly Sweden no
way is a special case because of oil and
I'd rather just put it aside because it
is a special case but Norway and Sweden
and sorry Denmark and Sweden which and I
know less about Finland those two
countries have a much more robust free
market in a sense if you will than the
United States has it's easier even in
places that have high union membership
it's even easier to fire an employee
much easier to fire an employee in
Sweden that it is in the United States
suddenly that it is in California it's
easier to start a business it's quicker
faster easier smooth and a lot of
businesses Scandinavia than it is in the
United States the the the the the main
way in which the United States and and
and Sweden and Denmark differ is the
Sweden Denmark have higher taxes and
they redistribute much more wealth yes
there is much more of a welfare welfare
as you know redistribution of wealth I
think here it's important because I made
the point of socialism to do a little
bit of history so indulge me for a
second sure before 1870 Sweden and I'm
gonna use Sweden because it's the one I
know but I power lost other countries
Sweden was the poorest country in Europe
I mean literally was massive poverty a
lot of squeeze left Sweden and that's
why we have a lot of Swedes in the
United States which I'll get to later um
tween 1870 and about you know 1950 maybe
1960 Sweden had the most capitalist
economy
in Europe arguably maybe even in the
world it had more capitalism more
freedom less regulation less
redistribution wealth no real welfare
state or very little welfare state
suddenly in the early days increased a
little bit towards then than any other
country in you open it was the richest
country in you had many many large
corporations it was incredible success
to it in 1960 around 1960 someway in the
50s they switched to socialism and they
took it more seriously in the 60s and
70s than they do today they regulated
they nationalized they took over the
means of production which is what
socialism advocates for they nationalize
the means of production and they
basically turned Sweden into a relative
by European Standard poorer country
it lost its industrial lead it suddenly
it was not anywhere near the richest
country in Europe and by 1979 I like to
joke but it's not a joke it's a reality
that the biggest business the most
income producing business in all of
Sweden was the rock group ABBA
and the second biggest business was
johan book who then left a monaco and
and took away all his tax money from
sweet sweet osa was a mess was a
disaster and nadine in 1984 sweden was
on the verge of bankruptcy
it was the Greece of Europe and in since
1994 to today whether the left or the
right is a being in power they have
reduced regulations there for example
established school vouchers they have
increased business freedom they have
even decreased the welfare state still
robust but they've decreased the welfare
state and you know they've had just as
many right-of-center governments as they
have left of centre governments and
indeed in most of these countries now
have right-of-center governments because
of some of the problem of socialism
created there so ah they came back to
prominence became rich again if you will
and now you be used this as models by
the left in the United States as they
become more capitalist okay fine so
you've late you've laid out your
framework but I have to tell you my
reading of the history is just
completely different than what you're
saying and we can't we can't possibly
both be right but you what you've just
presented runs completely counter to my
recent reading of the history of the
Swedish economy the
the Swedish hold on let me let me give
you my under my understanding the Social
Democratic Party of Sweden which is
basically what we would consider like a
social Social Democrats in the United
States it's capitalism with significant
social safety net redistribute
redistribution etc it had its golden era
from the late 20s early 30s for for many
many decades during which you just
described that they were one of the most
capitalist countries that is not at all
the history that I understand it was
strongly socially Democratic I then I'm
aware of the decline of that contingent
of sentiment in Sweden but that's been a
decline that's been as as I recall from
around 2006 forward not lining up at all
with what you're talking about
and even still they've been modest
declines not what you described so are
my understanding of the history is just
totally different so I would suggest
looking at one number I mean you might
disagree that this number is
representative but one number yeah look
at the percentage of government spending
as a percentage of the economy from 1870
to today and I think you'll start seeing
a shrink from 1994 I think you're such
seeing it explode in the 1960s and not
in the 1920s okay I don't have that in
front of me that maybe it's a good
number to look at and and by the way the
same the same thing nineteen eighty four
is a good number to look at Canada
Canada in nineteen ninety-four starts
shrinky government spending as a
percentage of the economy it's reversed
lately but those were years in which a
lot of countries experimented with
socialism kind of redirected their
efforts um let me say one other thing
about Sweden and Denmark Swedes and
Danes who live in the United States and
there were a lot of them in Minnesota
and Wisconsin a richer by a lot it's not
even close
live in bigger homes drive nicer cause
and all of that just as happy just as
happy if not happier just as healthy
life expectancy is just the same as they
aren't Sweden so you know I'm a little
suspicious of happiness studies you know
I come from a family where admitting to
be happy is yeah suspect I think I think
culture certain culture
treat happiness differently well yes if
you've ever been at a at a Shabbat
dinner you would know that that is a
y'all complain all the time and if
you're not complaining there's something
wrong with you so you know the culture
has a big part of it but there be
studies about this what a Danish
immigrants how did they do in America
now granted there's a bias they caused
certain people emigrate yeah there's a
self-selection bias because someone who
is more someone who's coming from those
countries is is coming from a different
economic starting point acknowledged
very hard to control for self selection
bias yeah in these kind of studies but
it's also I think wrong to say you know
Swedes are X and if you look at how rich
Sweden is in Denmark is and I know
wealth is not the only factor but it is
a factor Sweden and Denmark would score
on a GDP per capita adjusted for cost of
living somewhere in the 40s in terms of
if they were states in the United States
they're far from being the richest the
far from the mean they're significantly
below the mean so I don't know why we
should strive towards that yes there's
less inequality but their costs to
having less inequality which means less
wealth less economic growth less
economic success and also I would I
suspect less ambition less
entrepreneurship less innovation less
progress yeah but I think a lot of those
statistics maybe are a little bit they
maybe don't inform us deeply about what
we're really trying to evaluate because
in the United States you you know a lot
of the impressive numbers in terms of
income are driven by relatively few
people that are earning a lot a lot of
money I mean that's just a mathematical
reality I'm not passing judgment on it
yeah so for that you can look at mediums
okay but I think that there's this thing
when you look at mediums it's just if
it's no it's not true that it's driven
that way that's absolutely true but let
me get to my point even if we disagree
on that even if we disagree on that
you're on I think what's important to
consider is if you we need to somehow
account for the positive societal impact
of there being less inequality the
positive societal impact of people not
having to worry about I need to choose
my job based on whether I can afford the
health insurance pretty
based on how much they pay and how much
I pay and knowing that you're never
going to go bankrupt if you get sick
there's a lot of these things that have
significant value to one's happiness so
I don't think it's it's good to discount
the happiness stuff that don't
necessarily show up in like GDP per
capita so again I think if you look at
Swedes and Danes here they're just as
happiest over there and here they face
the threat of bankruptcy because we're
healthcare whatever so I think you can
control all that but look I think it's
exactly the other way around
mmm I took it I think that protected
yeah exactly
but protecting people from the downside
that given them this robust safety net
is actually destructive to their own
self-esteem to their own you know
ability to thrive not just to live yes
if your standard for living is am just
surviving somehow then yeah welfare
states great right but if your standard
of living is to live which is my stand
of living to live to the full extent
that a human be can and I believe and I
believe and I mean I know a lot of
people disagree with me on this but I
believe that every human being on the
planet has the capability of living and
I don't want to discriminate based on
where they come from or based on any
aspect or based on how wealthy they
happen to be at a given point in their
time I want everybody to have the
opportunity
psychologically morally and in reality
to fully live their lives to the full
extent possible and I think these
societies become mediocre they become
dull they a Glee get everybody to the
median and long term and granted a long
term is a long term as Keynes said well
dead in the long term but in the long
term I don't think those models are
sustainable in it and I think you're
seeing some angst in America but you're
also seeing some angst in Sweden I'm not
sure you'd want to move to Sweden right
now there's a lot of political ranks
there's a lot of political upheaval
there's a rise in what I think both of
us would think is a really bad kind of
white leaning nationalism in Sweden
which is really really bad and there's
lots of reasons for it you know
including immigration but it's not
limited to immigration there's a lot of
negative consequences to these robust
welfare states that I think affect
individuals but more important but all
so effect cultures as a whole and the
long-term viability of those cultures
and let me just say this and I know it's
not fair because we're about to close
and there's no time to argue about it
but I think that the more socialized you
make America not socialism completely
but the more socialized you make America
the less production you have here that
that's innovation the less progress the
less new ideas the less breakthrough
stuff will happen and everybody in the
world will suffer from it including the
Swedes and Danes because the fact is
that most innovation happens here not by
accident now because we have better
genes now because of anything like that
but there's still marginally in certain
parts of economy like a little bit in
health care and much more in technology
more freedom here than anywhere else and
we are carrying on our shoulders the
rest of the world and when the United
States become more socialized in health
care everything else everybody in the
world will be worse off well my audience
knows I vehement ly disagree with that
but to go back a little bit you know I
think the I think you're right that I
want everybody to have the opportunity
to truly live and not just exist as you
suggested I believe that most people
have that drive and thus welfare
programs are not going to serve to
dissuade very many people to continue
pursuing that I mean listen when I was
in college I worked at the now-defunct
Circuit City chain and at a certain
point in when they were just before they
went bankrupt they laid off a bunch of
people and I was one of those people and
I was able to collect unemployment for I
think it was like 39 weeks or something
like that I was in school I knew that
this was part of a path to eventually
doing something else and the money
merely allowed me to continue what it
was that I was driven to do which is get
my education and eventually become an
entrepreneur and start a radio show and
a TV show and all of this stuff there
was it's certainly possible that someone
with that unemployment money might have
said this is great I just want this for
as long as possible I think it is a tiny
fraction of the population and I think
most people will be driven to achieve
regardless of getting a little help
along the way
I think people people people affected by
the incentives that they get
if you tax something you get less of it
if you subsidize something you get more
of it and yes you're right there are
lots of people who will do like you and
and and and be ambitious in spite of it
but there are a lot of people who won't
and who lose because of it because they
could have been ambitious but now you're
subsidizing something you're subsidizing
a behavior they don't want but beyond
that I've already argued that I think
the whole issue is immoral that is
taking money from me and giving it to
you for unemployment insurance is
immoral
you were living off of me without asking
my consent and and that I think is wrong
anymore but you chose to move here and
work write it and add to that yeah look
and work to have my money taken from me
but somebody else nobody there are -
this used to come here to live off of
welfare because I think that would have
been wrong I came here to work and to
make a living for myself and create
wealth but I also think that again we're
comparing a mixed economy to mixed
economy and I know this sounds strange
to your audience but I have no doubt in
my mind really know though that in a
capitalist system there is so many job
opportunities that you don't need that
unemployment insurance that circuitcity
year would be shutting down and they'd
be five other people trying to hire you
because in every case again in every
case where capitalism has been tried
there are more jobs than there are
opportunity there more jobs than there
are people
that is why capitalist countries draw in
massive amounts of immigration and
Status countries nobody wants to move
there because there are jobs in
capitalist countries and they're more
and more and more and more jobs and in
the more technology the more robots I'm
here to tell you there'll be more jobs
not fewer jobs so I think capitalism
creates and also my job then is it again
there's any simple economic argument for
it because we leap we let people have
invest and save and make a profit and
they that's what creates jobs it's not
government to create jobs it's not well
for the creates jobs it's not
consumption that creates jobs
it's investment production savings the
create job so the Mauryan has a pretty
big role to play as well demand look you
could drop any human being in a mall
demand is easy demand is uninteresting
economically demand it should
studied in economics no but the man
doesn't mean wanting stuff the demand in
the economic sense yeah but wait so
here's the point about consumption and
production in order to consume what must
you do put aside the welfare state what
must you do you must work and if you
don't work because you're getting
welfare somebody else had to work in
order for the money to be taken from
them and given to you so behind every
single act of consumption there is
production that created the money so you
can consume and but there's a second act
of production because you'll buying
something that something had to be
created so for every one act of
consumption there are many many many
acts of production indeed there is no
such thing as consumption without
production we first you know human
beings were for capitalism we grew the
food that we ate that's we produced and
we consumed that's it it's only when we
started having division of labor and we
started to have a capitalist economy we
started actually being having a surplus
where we could actually go and consume
but the surplus is created from
production so unless we focus on the
production side economics is a bogus
science and indeed today it has become
in my view a you know a science of
charlatans it I'm serious about this
there's some bad economics being taught
but I would argue it's a lot of the the
neoclassical stuff but we probably would
not agree on what it is that's not good
modern monetary theory the Keynesian
stuff the New Keynesian stuff and much
of the monetarist stuff much of the
monitor stuff it's just not true it's
not how the world functions and you you
hear this consumption drives the economy
it doesn't guys to consume you have to
produce and produce and produce so what
we should be focused on is maximizing
production so look III don't believe in
equality of outcome I don't even believe
in equality of opportunities cuz I agree
with Paul Krugman that equality of
opportunities as a form of equality of
outcome
I believe in maximizing opportunities
and I believe in equality before the law
and equality of rights of freedom and I
believe in maximizing opportunities and
the system that has proven itself
throughout history and if it was
practiced today would blow your mind
that maximizes opportunities for all of
us and and primarily for the ambitious
poor for the poor like you who
want a job who want to be successful in
life is capitalism and to me the
greatest thing justice is to the
ambitious poor that the poor in the
inner cities who can't find a job
because the jobs don't exist why because
we've driven them out of existence
through in-state intervention and of
course I've given him a lousy education
sue state did you get intervention well
a very different perspective for many in
our audience from your on Brook who's
the chairman of the Aisne Rand Institute
and host of the yeren Brook show I think
we did find some maybe not minor but
moderate points of agreement in some way
on a few things is maybe though that I
could sum it up your on has been really
great having these conversations with
you absolutely it was fun thanks for
having me out